ce mardi au stade de porchefontaine à
versailles les visages sont concentrés à
l'aube de cette nouvelle saison
cette année le club fait son grand
retour en fédérale 3 après trois ans
d'absence
à ce niveau on va essayer de surfer sur
la dynamique de la dernière puisque on
est sorti d'une très belle saison en
honneur avec deux titres de champion
d'île de france et du coup il ya un
super état d'esprit
tous les joueurs qui étaient présents
les dernières sont très contents de
reprendre la saison avec beaucoup
d'impatience et beaucoup beaucoup
d'envié donc c'est plutôt très positif
pour nous puisque notion n'est on a à
coeur de relever les challenges delà de
la fédérale 3 l'objectif cette année le
maintien avec au minimum 10 victoires
pour réussir à atteindre ce chiffre
un recrutement ciblé a été effectué cet
été il ya douze recrues cette saison
principalement faite de fait 3
principalement des des arrières voilà on
verra ça s'intègre avec le groupe
actuellement
normalement ça devrait correspondre à
nos attentes
dans leur poule les versailles et
tomberont notamment contre boulogne
billancourt auxerre ou encore bobigny va
falloir travailler dur dur dur pour
hommes pour essayer d'être au niveau
être au niveau de la poule parce qu'avec
à une poule qui est qui et qui va ta
c'est compliqué
à mon sens donc falloir bien travailler
et s'investir deux fois plus qu'on a pu
faire dépasser premier test ce dimanche
15 septembre à 15 heures sur le terrain
de massif central une victoire et la
saison sera parfaitement lancé